[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing james potter
the potter family ancestry and one of
the deathly hallows
more specifically we're going to be
discussing one halo in particular
the invisibility cloak now the
invisibility cloak
if you were previously unaware it's a
powerful magical artifact that once
belonged
to ignotus peverell the youngest brother
from the tale of three brothers
a story outlining the origin of each
hallow the plot surrounds the three
wizard brothers
and their ability to cheat death for a
short period of time
after conquering death a personification
of death under the guise of
congratulating them
awards them with three gifts the elder
wand
the resurrection stone and the
invisibility cloak
long story short each brother chose one
of the gifts the death had presented
them
ignotus the youngest chose the
invisibility cloak
cadmus the middle brother chose the
resurrection stone
and antioch the eldest chose the elder
wand
from the tale of three brothers there
were once three brothers who were
traveling along
a lonely winding road at twilight in
time
the brothers reached a river too deep to
wade through and too dangerous to swim
across
however these brothers were learned in
the magical arts
and so they simply waved to their ones
and made a bridge appear
across the treacherous water they were
halfway across it when they found their
path blocked
by a hooded figure and death spoke to
them
he was angry that he had been cheated
out of three new victims
four travellers usually drowned in the
river but death was cunning
he pretended to congratulate the three
brothers upon their magic
and said that each had earned a prize
for having been clever enough to evade
him
however after encountering death the
first time
it didn't take long for both the eldest
brother who acquired the elder wand
and the middle brother who acquired the
resurrection stone
to meet death again the two older
brothers had made foolish
unwise decisions that led to their
reunion with death
and ultimately their demise the youngest
brother was certainly the wisest of the
bunch
and then death asked the third and
youngest brother what he would like
the youngest brother was the humblest
and also the wisest of the brothers
and he did not trust death so he asked
for something that would enable him
to go forth from that place without
being followed by death
and death most unwillingly handed over
his own
cloak of invisibility all three of these
objects are massively instrumental in
the harry potter story
and while the elder wand is a huge plot
driver the invisibility cloak
definitely ended up being the most
useful halo for harry
which is interesting because it was
handed down to him by his father
after james's death it was kept safe
until harry was old enough to appreciate
it
dumbledore anonymously gifted the cloak
to harry in the philosopher's stone
his next present also contained candy a
large box of chocolate frogs from
hermione
this left only one parcel harry picked
it up and felt it
it was very light he unwrapped it
something fluid in silvery grey went
slithering to the floor
where it lay in gleaming folds one
gasped
i've heard of those he said in a hushed
voice dropping the box of every flavor
beans he'd gotten from hermione
if that's what i think it is they're
really rare and really valuable
what is it harry picked the shining
silvery cloth of the floor
it was strange to the touch like water
woven into material
it's an invisibility cloak said ron a
look of awe
on his face i'm sure it is try it on
harry threw the cloak around his
shoulders and ron gave a yell
it is look down harry looked down at his
feet
but they were gone he dashed to the
mirror
sure enough his reflection looked back
at him
just his head suspended in mid-air his
body completely invisible
he pulled the cloak over his head and
his reflection vanished completely
there's a note said ron suddenly a note
fell out of it
harry pulled off the cloak and seized
the letter written in narrow
loopy writing he had never seen before
with the following words
your father left this in my possession
before he died it is time it was
returned to you
use it well a very merry christmas to
you there was no signature
harry stared at the note ron was
admiring the cloak
i'd give anything for one of these he
said anything
what's the matter nothing said harry he
felt very strange
who had sent the cloak had it really
once belonged to his father
and the answer to harry's question there
is of course it belonged to his father
but how did james potter get his hands
on one of the
fabled deathly hallows the magical item
purported
to have once been in the hands of death
himself as it turns out
the magical item simply came into his
possession via natural inheritance
pottermore explains the potter family
and the passing down of the cloak
the wizarding family of potters descends
from 12th century wizard linford of
sinchome
a locally well beloved and eccentric man
whose nickname
the postera became corrupted in time to
potter
linford's eldest son hardwin married a
beautiful young witch by the name of
violanthi
peverell who came from the village of
godric's hollow
she was the granddaughter of ignotus
peverell in the absence of male heirs
she the eldest of her generation had
inherited her grandfather's invisibility
cloak
it was milanthy explained to hardwin a
tradition in her family
that the possession of this cloak
remained a secret and her new husband
respected her wishes from this time on
the cloak was handed down to the eldest
in each new generation
the potters continued to marry their
neighbours occasionally muggles
and to live in the west of england for
several generations
each one adding to the family coffers by
their hard work and
it must be said by the quiet brand of
ingenuity
that had characterized their forebear
linfred
henry potter who was a direct descendant
of hardwin and iolanthi
served on the wizangamot from 1913 to
1921.
henry's son was called fleemont potter
it was fleemont
who took the family gold and quadrupled
it by creating magical
sleek easy's hair potion two drops tames
even the most bothersome barnet
he sold the company at fast profit when
he retired but
no amount of riches could compensate him
or his wife euphemia
for their childlessness they had quite
given up hope of a son or daughter
when to their shock and surprise
euphemia found that she was pregnant
and their beloved boy james was born
flemant and euphemia lived long enough
to see james marry a muggle-born girl
called lily evans
but not to meet their grandson harry
dragon pox carried them off within days
of each other
due to their advanced age and james
potter then inherited
ignotus peripherals invisibility cloak
dumbledore who was privy to the cloak's
existence
also explains the origins of the cloak
to harry
the cloak as you know now travelled down
through the ages
father to son mother to daughter right
down to ignotus's last living descendant
who was born as ignotus was in the
village of godric's hollow
dumbledore smiled at harry me you
you have guessed i know why the cloak
was in my possession on the night your
parents died
james had showed it to me just a few
days previously and that's it for this
video
hopefully that clears up any questions
about the existence of the cloak
and how it came into the possession of
harry's father
james until next time remember
if you want to know what a man's like
take a good look at how he treats his
inferiors
not his equals